foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Thursday December 1st I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
in a bankruptcy filing the new CEO of
FTX John J Ray says the crypto exchange
displayed a quote complete failure of
corporate controls and said there was a
complete absence of trustworthy
financial information but former
employees say that Liz a fair attitude
toward risk and compliance extended back
into founder Sam bankman Freed's history
former staff at his trading firm Alameda
research say years earlier they quit in
part because of the way bankman freed
handled risk and accounting issues so
what can that history teach us about
what went down at FTX
joining us to discuss this is special
writer for the Wall Street Journal
Gregory Zuckerman hi Greg thanks for
joining us oh it's a pleasure you a lot
of people have heard of FTX since the
crisis with it began and now a lot of
people have heard of Alameda research
because of that but can you take us
through the creation of Alameda I mean
how did it get started of course so Sam
bankman freed the man who's at the helm
of this crypto exchange that's collapsed
called FDX after MIT after working at a
firm called Jane Street a trading firm
he left to start something called
Alameda research this was going to be a
firm that would focus on
cryptocurrencies and trade them uh
quasi-hedge fund type of firm and this
was we're talking 2017 about two years
before he started FTX so the first
business he started was Alameda research
now some former employees of Alameda
research are saying they quit in part
over begman Freed's risk tolerance what
kind of risks are they describing in
their accounts what sort of criticism
are they putting out there yes what
happened was early on we're talking the
fall of 2017 a rift developed in this
new Young trading firm a senior employee
senior staffer senior Traders started to
get nervous at what sambang poon fried
was doing or rather what he wasn't doing
what he wasn't doing was embracing
accepting just sort of conventional
proper standard risk controls accounting
measures compliance the kind of stuff
that most everybody else in the trading
world is fine with measurements of who's
doing what with the money where the
money is going how much they're making
what's being allocated they had money
for their firm you know buying desks
buying computers that kind of thing and
they had money me to trade and it was
being commingled mixed together and it
all worried people at the firm and they
said to Sam hey we can't trade like this
we need better measurements accounting
and otherwise to kind of Judge where the
money's going and he resisted their
efforts to incorporate and embrace some
of these risk accounting and other
measures why is that such a big deal
frankly the early employees point to the
recent problems and say well geez what
we were worried about that was a
foreshadowing of the problems that were
ahead and in some ways it says to us
from the outside that wow these problems
could have been avoided had Sam
bankmanfreen embrace the suggestions of
his colleagues how do we know all this
information so we spoke to a number of
people close to the matter so a series
of interviews and there were documents
there were contemporaneous documents
written by Sam banquen freed in 2018 to
explain the rift to explain the split
why so many senior people left his firm
as Sam begman freed responded
so what Sam banquin Freud has said is
that yes early on at the firm there was
a rift there was a fight it was pushed
back his colleagues were upset at him
for these very reasons the fact that he
resisted the accounting and other
controls compliance Etc but what he said
is that subsequently he did make some
changes in terms of being a better boss
listening to his employees having more
transparency so I think he would argue
that well some of the recommendations
that they pushed for yes I resisted them
initially but later I embraced them I
mean you mentioned that they raise these
concerns with bankman freed but did they
raise them with anyone else yeah so they
did raise these concerns and share them
with others in particular with some of
the early investors in the firm and they
said to some of the early investors hey
um this firm Alameda research and
samband freed are not trading properly
and not starting they're not initiating
their firm in a proper way and that was
kind of it it's important to keep in
mind that we're talking a period again
the fall 2017 through the spring of 2018
when this firm Palomino research was
relatively small did not have any
individual investors it's not clear they
would have been able to get anyone's
attention one of the big issues in this
crypto bankruptcy is how customers funds
from FTX were used for Investments by
Alameda research on Wednesday bankman
freed was speaking at the deal book
Summit and he said he didn't knowingly
co-mingle the funds and said it was a
failure of oversight on his part but I
wonder if knowing more about what went
on in the early years of Alameda
research will help with understanding
the fall of FTX you know will it help
customers regain some of their money or
at least you know know what happened
well it's a good question I think it
sheds light on the firm his management
style his approach to risk his approach
to accounting I think it could undercut
an argument perhaps from bank and freed
and and others they may come and argue
well you know we didn't know any better
we just started this firm and we yeah we
messed up and we're really sorry but we
were just you know young guys cut us
some slack and what I think our article
kind of shows is there were early
warnings and there were concerns issued
by colleagues of Sam Baker and freed all
right that's special writer for the Wall
Street Journal Gregory Zuckerman thanks
so much for joining us Greg thank you
Zoe and have a good one and that's it
for today's Tech news briefing if you're
looking for more Tech stories check out
our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]